اعترض هدف في سماء مدينه ايلات من غير
الواضح ان كان صاروخا فالسيا اطلق من
اليمن او طائره مسيره بدوي سافرات الانذار
تحديدا في مدينه ايلات جنوب اسرائيل على
البحر الاحمر السفينه جينكو بيكاردي تعرضت
لهجوم بطا مسيره في خليج عدن ورغم
التحذيرات والجهود المتعدده فان الحوثيين
واصلوا هجماتهم نفذت القوات البحريه في
القوات المسلحه اليمنيه عمليه استهداف
لسفينه جينكو بيكاردي الامريكيه الحوثيون
يباغت القوه الامريكيه بهجوم جديد
والبنتاجون يندد على الفور بعد ان كان
يهدد بينما فرنسا تتنصل من الانضمام
للتحالف في البحر الاحمر ماكرون يحذر تل
ابيب فيما المانيا تمد العبريين بالذخائر
لمواصله الحرب مقترح داخلي في تل ابيب
لسحب الثقه من حكومه النتنياهو الفصائل
تحدد شروطها لادخال الادويه للرهائن
المحتجزين في القطاع ومشروع عربي لادانه
ايران انتخابات تايوان تعيد توتر المنطقه
الى الاضواء مع الصين وواشنطن تعلنها
للعالم ليس لدينا وعاء سحري يمكننا من
خلاله تمويل اوكرانيا وبيلاروسيا تتبنى
العقيده نويه وكيف تتهم الغرب بتزويد
روسيا بمكونات
عسكريه الدوله اساس
الاستقرار البدايه من البحر الاحمر حيث
كان الرئيس الفرنسي امانويل ماكرون قد
اعلن ان بلاده قررت عدم الانضمام الى
الائتلاف الذي تقوده الولايات المتحده في
توجيه ضربات ضد الحوثيين اليمنيين لتجنب
التصعيد هناك اكدت متحدثه الخارجيه
الروسيه ماريا زخروف في حديث لراديو
سبوتنيك ان التحالف الغربي لا ياخذ في
الاعتبار مقتل المدنيين في اليمن ودول
اخرى لانه يتطلع بعد ذلك الى اعاده كتابه
التاريخ بما يناسبه وقالت يقصفون اي هدف
في اليمن غير ابهين بالمدنيين متطلعين
لاعاده كتابه التاريخ وبعد ان كانت
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه اعلنت تصنيف
حركه انصار الله الحوثيين في اليمن كمنظمه
ارهابيه عالميه في قرار سينفذ بعد 30 يوما
ورد الناطق الرسمي باسم الحوثيين محمد عبد
السلام مؤكدا ان القرار الامريكي الاخير
لن يؤثر على موقف الجماعه الثابت الداعم
لشعب القطاع كما ارجع القرار الامريكي
الاخير الى اغراض سياسيه وشدد على ان
القرار لن يكون له تاثير كبير على الارض
لان اليمن خاضع لحصار اقتصادي امريكي اصلا
منذ سنوات وها هو المصدر يتحدث نحن نعتقد
ان امريكا تستخدم التصنيف لاغراض سياسيه
لما يخدم مصالحها ليس لديها اي معايير
قانونيه اليمن بالاساس هو يخضع لحصار
اقتصادي من قبل امريكا قبل ذلك كان مسؤول
امريكي قال لقناه الجزيره ان سفينه تجاريه
مملوكه لشركه امريكيه تعرضت لهجوم من
مناطق يسيطر عليها الحوثيون في اليمن
واصاب الهجوم السفينه ولا يمكننا الافصاح
عن السلاح المستخدم واي اضرار محتمله وفق
تعبيره كما اعلن الحوثيون استهداف سفينه
جينكو بيكاردي الامريكيه في خليج عدن بعدد
من الصواريخ البحريه المناسبه مؤكدين ان
الاصابه كانت دقيقه ومباشره وكان
البنتاغون رد ب على الحوثيين ان يسالوا
انفسهم كم سيتعرض من قدراتهم للتقوي جراء
هجماتهم غير المشروعه وقال المتحدث باسم
البنتاغون باتريك رايدر لن نتردد في
الدفاع عن قوتنا والتجاره الدوليه في
البحر الاحمر هناك قالت شبكه سي ان ان ان
عددا متزايدا من شركه التامين تفرض تغطيه
السفن الامريكيه والبريطانيه والعبريه في
البحر الاحمر خلاصه الامر تاتي من الغرب
هذه المره حيث كان وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
انطوني بلانك قد قال انه لن يكون هناك اي
تكمل اقليمي بالمنطقه دون الاعتراف بدوله
فلسطينيه ويجب تطوير سلطه فلسطينيه قادره
على الاعتناء بشعبها وفق تعبيره ولنتصور
في القطاع اعلن عضو المكتب السياسي
للفصائل موسى ابو مرزوق عن شروط جديده
لتسليم الادويه للرهائن حيث نشر في حسابه
على منصه اكس انهم وضعوا عده شروط فمقابل
لعلبه دواء اي للرهائن الف علبه لابناء
شعب القطاع مضيفا ان توفير الدواء عبر
دوله يثقون بها وليس عبر فرنسا وقال ابو
مرزوق انه من ضمن شروط منع تفتيش شحنات
الادويه من جيش العبريين على ذكر فرنسا
حذر الرئيس الفرنسي امانويل ماكرو من ان
استمرار الكيان في شان عمليات عسكريه
دقيقه بما يكفي في القطاع يطرح خطرا على
امنها على المدى الطويل بالمقابل كشفت
مجلا ديرشبيغل الالمانيه ان برلين تدرس
تزويد الجيش الع بذخائر الدبابات اللازمه
لمواصله الحرب في القطاع ودعم تلبيب في
جميع ساحات الحرب القتاليه الاقليميه التي
تحيط بها واليكم المصدر قالت وسائل اعلام
المانيه ان الحكومه بتستعد لتصدير اسلحه
متفجره الى سلطات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في
الداخل العبري قالت القناه 12 العبريه ان
حزب العمل سيقدم مقترحا لسحب الثقه من
الحكومه بسبب عجزها عن استعاده الرهائن
فيما افاد الكاتب العبري بي مايكل بان لو
تم توصيل جهاز كشف الكاذب بفريق الدفاع
العبري لانهارت شبكه الكهرباء في لاهاي
مشيرا الى ان تلبيب انكرت لسنوات وجود
الشعب الفلسطيني وبذلت جهودا حثيثه لانكار
وجوده واضاف في مقال لصحيفتي ارتز ان
تلبيب رات في تلك التهمه فرصتها للتركيز
على محاوله لدحض وبالتالي تحويل النقاش عن
جميع الفضائح الاخرى التي ترتكبها في
القطاع عربيا طرحت جامعه الدول العربيه
مشروع قرار للتصويت بشان ادانه الضربه
الايرانيه التي استهدفت اربيل شمالي
العراق والى شرق اسيا حيث اسفرت نتائج
الانتخابات في تايوان عن فوز لاي تشينغ تي
المؤيد لاستقلال الجزيره ما يشير الى
استمرار التوتر في المنطقه وفي المقابل
تتوقع بلومبرج ان تصل خسائر الاقتصاد
العالمي الى نحو عشرا ترليونات دولار في
حال اندلاع حرب بين تايبي وبكين بينما قال
وزير الخارجيه الامريكي انطوني بلينكن ان
اي صراع حول تايوان سيكون له عواقب وخيمه
لان نصف التجاره العالميه الدوليه يمر عبر
مضيق
تايوان تنصل
امريكي الغرب يشد الحبل ثم يرخي قليلا
ليعود الشد من جديد هنا قال وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي انطوني بلينكن في مقابله مع شبكه
سي ان بي سي ليس لدى الولايات المتحده
وعاء سحري يمكنها من خلاله تمويل اوكرانيا
دون تنسيق الطلبات في الكونجرس فيما قال
رئيس وزراء سلوفاكيا روبرت فيسو في مؤتمر
صحفي مع نظيره الهنغاري فيكتور اوربان ان
المساعدات العسكريه الغربيه لاوكرانيا لا
معنى لها ولا تؤدي الا الى المزيد من
ضحايا الصراع وكانت الحكومه الالمانيه
اعلنت ان برلين ستقدم مساعدات عسكريه
لاوكرانيا بقيمه تزيد عن سبعه مليارات
يورو في العام الحالي هذا وافاض عضو
البرلمان الاوروبي الايرلندي ميك والاس
خلال اجتماع للبرلمان الاوروبي بان رغبه
الغرب في الصراع مع روسيا دمرت
اوكرانيا هنا اعترف وزير الاقتصاد
الالماني روبرت هابيك بان الاقتصاد
الالماني لا يتلقى اموال كافيه بسبب
الانفاق على دعم اوكرانيا مضيفا ان
المانيا في وضع صعب للغايه حقا لسببين
اولا على عكس الدول الاخرى كانت امدادات
الطاقه لالمانيا مبنيه على حد كبير على
الاعتماد على الغاز الروسي وقد اعطانا هذا
ميزه تنفسيه في الماضي وكان مربحا للغايه
من جهته قال الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
ان بريطانيا اقنعت الاوكرانيين عبر رئيس
وزرائها السابق بورس جونسون بانهاء
مفاوضات الحل السلمي التي عقدت قبل نحو
عام
اما نائب رئيس مجلس الامن الروسي ديمت مد
فصرح ان احتمال نشو نزاع جديد مع اوكرانيا
بال 100% وذلك بغض النظر عن من يتولى
السلطه في كياف وع من ستدخل تلك الدوله في
التحالف معه في الطرف الاوكراني صرح مكتب
الرئاسه الاوكراني لوكاله رويترز بان
الشركه الغربيه زودت روسيا بمكونات
الكترونيه بقيمه 2.9 مليار دولار على
الرغم من سريان العقوبات ولننتقل الى
ميدان المعارك حيث صرح وزير الصناعات
الاستراتيجيه الاوكراني الكسندر كامشين
بان القوات الاوكرانيه استخدمت لاول مره
نظام دفاع جوي هجين يتكون من عنا صير من
الاسلحه السوفيتيه والغربيه فيما افادت
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه في تقريرها اليومي
بان الجيش الاوكراني خسن نحو
655 جنديا بين قتيل وجريح خلال 24 ساعه
ليفيد الباحث وعالم السياسه في جامعه
شيكاجو جون ميرشايمر بان القوات
الاوكرانيه لن تكون قادره على شن هجوم
مضاد جديد موضحا ان الغرب لن يتمكن بعد
الان من تصليح وتدريب الاوكرانيين حتى
بحلول عام
2025 ولن يتمكنوا من مقاومه الجيش الروسي
بحس سبوتنك وبعيدا عن اوكرانيا كشف وزير
الدفاع البلاروسي فيكتور خرين عن تبني
بلاده للعقيده النوويه وقال ان بلاروس
ستطرح عقيده عسكريه جديده تنص على استخدام
الاسلحه النوويه للمره الاولى في
[موسيقى]
تاريخها
ه